we're back a same old world
can you read my world
artax not a foul car um for you and me
rescuers down under Oh new wall yeah
those are pretty much all of them don't
you dare let me go I was very much all
the movies they very lovingly ripped off
of like almost shot for a shot I'm like
that Superman who was it I had mentions
to you but we got like really dark
talking about the explosion automatic uh
are you gonna edit this out of the fight
or do you just leave this in uh I'll
just leave it is the behind-the-scenes
well you holies there we go okay so we
might go in and out in terms of that but
the all mega exposure um I did want to
say just before I forget the sound of
lapis a--'s wings that slushee sound is
like the most disgusting things in them
like it sounds so uh do you have an
x-men whatever I like very like it
sounds like I'm listening to a porno
really everything you remember an x-men
whenever mystique or like morph what
changes someone else has got it and you
kind of get it cuz it's like bone and
flesh moving around and changing butts
like yeah what's supposed to be like
these elegant wings it is a little weird
it is how does water fly it is uh that
work it is some very wet nasty second I
got it is the only picture oh god I hope
there's no kids watch you see when a man
and a woman like each other just enough
um so this uh I do really like this
episode um a lot is you said you did - I
did - that's good we're done now we can
watch it let's go um no this is one of
those were it's like again kind of like
the one where Steven and peridot get to
know each other it's like we kind of
seen this before but it's done well and
I like it and it's charming and its
interest the opening felt like an
epilogue yeah alright let's go home just
like oh I know that happens at the end
of an episode but all right I really
like you want to show acknowledges that
a character has done a lot of shit and
they need to rest I love it
when all this stuff happens and then
either at the very end of the game the
next episode you just see him sleeping
it's like you get it you know it's like
you're not a machine you need to relax
and it feel I have seen shit and I'm
tagging it out here so I really like
opening up with that with her sleeping
and I like her trying to take off not
knowing where to go um you know that
voice is uh yeah I can't forgot what a
fragile sounding voice she's a fragile
looking care no I mean but he's gonna
snap like a twig but wouldn't you know
all the stuff like she's going through
and everything it's like it kind of
makes sense but yet just just the owning
through that voice and kind of shakiness
in the crackling as the character design
her shoulders always kind of hunched her
here is gonna be like even the outfits
not like armor pearl like is very
rail-thin
- but she carries herself stronger don't
feel like she's gonna snap like lash I
just stands I feel like she's just gonna
like turn into a puddle anytime swoosh
but the same sexual whoosh um hey you're
a say another surgeon here yeah don't
don't worry what the shit is it's that
just little kid tug this girl but
friendship and emotions I got a dirty it
up somehow man we're watching cartoon
you got a dick it up man you got a dick
it off Oh actually this funny the irony
is I'm a sucker for friendship stories I
really like this one a lot yeah um and I
especially love when they go into the
backstory and I love the way they show
with those just simple shapes simple
colors you totally like eyes owned out
for like one second but I you know what
I think I found out the same moment say
wait a minute somebody watch somewhere
in the middle of the story it's like and
then I was found and then they were
interrogating me I'm like wait I was
like it was like Spaceballs OHS what
where who the young I completely missed
it was like was it the rebellion they
got her and I that I can't I'm assuming
it's the bad side but I'm not positive
you know it's one the two sides we know
that like you know what is her family
still sad I mean the rebellion is pearl
and on rebellions the good side
garnet and amethyst lobotomize she
seemed it did not be on a psychosis in
the fracture Marian yeah um she'll just
sit around watching you know whatever
the Sun or whatever and then just shits
just exploding some goes hi turns her
into it wasn't that she's found out
funny is this this show lulled me into
such a false sense of security that this
is gonna be slow
that story was delivered pay attention
oh shit what'd I miss
yeah no I missed fell explain it to us
in accountants yeah I missed who put it
who put her on the mirror and was like
getting answers out of her I missed that
barb probably just gonna go back and
watch it right yeah so I I'm assuming
it's the bad guys I mean maybe it's a
rebellion but that sounds unlikely but I
would be interests
I don't like the way you say bad guys
they're just doing the children destroys
no bird guys in bad guys such as guys
guys it's this is what nature is that a
guy there's no men's it's just gals
it's just gems Jim Jim it's man named
Jim um this is totally outreach it's a
truly outrageous angry array just um but
I didn't watch the show much so it's
just but but yeah they're just it's a
fight for survival but still good or bad
it's just whoever is strongest wins
that's what Darwin said I was like you
know they're trying to like mind you
earth and take over the earth and get
around the people and stuff but that's
only bad for us no but we're us but what
do we do every day we march into a
fucking forest chop it down build a farm
strip mine the fuck out of it and then
next thing you know we've got Jersey
yeah but we're us I just love that
phrasing we're awesome yeah see like
it's almost like a Zen reset just don't
think it are we the bad guys well I
think it's clear yes we've always been
the bad guy we're man we are white men
living in suburbia we are we are always
the bad guys were evil we mess up all
right soon but not all of us are evil
there's got to be someone out the dali
lama's it's not one person exactly one
person is not a dick on this point the
prophesize one as the movie though is
tena yeah
um but uh I love the fact that they've
clearly been to Jersey
um they appear just as much as you that
was great
I will say this well first off I found
it weird well I guess it's Jersey not
New Jersey but I find a weird that's
like oh it's Empire City I'm like oh
then you're Z and then this is Jersey
I'm like once you call it something else
you called that Empire like I'm but a
night some things never change I you
know either single nobility Empire State
I know it's a reference to New York but
still I'm like you called it by that
name in Jersey still Jersey um I I will
say this I do feel a little bad for
Jersey cuz having been to New York I'm
like New York isn't exactly paradise s
oh no no no like so I'm like I'm like
New York gets all this credits in there
and it's like an and Jersey oh no no no
I have imagined well I will go out on
the limb and offend both and say I am
NOT a fan of either it's just new I will
say this about New York City uh you know
cuz all the stereotypes you hear are
correct there are a ton of dicks but you
get why it's wall-to-wall people you
have to fight for your space it's like a
fight for your right to move it's like
literally if we add between everybody
Tokyo without the politeness yeah um but
New York also has everything like
everything is there everything like a
lot of its affordable in terms of food
like this amazing food oh it can go a
double buy because it it has amazing
culture and it has all this stuff in
Jersey from what I've seen it usually
doesn't it just has the dick so like in
the barrios I live in Jersey just live
there so they can get out of Jersey hey
it's felonies like I Victory Garden
State I have a dream to go to Jersey and
nobody says that you know nobody there I
understand alright boy were they afford
before the park Jersey acts like Jersey
before Tony Soprano tells us let's make
one thing perfectly clear the part of
Jersey new you near New York is really
the worst part yes the rest of Jersey
X's in a bad I have to say that is it is
called the Garden State for reason it's
not it's not awful and let's be honest
probably that part of Jersey is bad
because New York's evil is see
it's the shitty near New York part of it
um it's like New York's and snuck in
said hey you're in New York now you're
right okay
New York I mean you're Cossack we
applied X okay New York does have
everything and there is a very good
reason for that because there would be
no other fucking reason to live in York
City no reason whatsoever if they didn't
have good food and some culture there it
would if it would be like a fucking
Shyamalan movie everybody would be
killing themselves what can you tell
where Chicagoans but there's nothing
wrong with Chicago at all we're we're
fucking amazing especially on prime
still number one I'm number one oh yeah
oh no that that's not your car that's
only because we're a large city there's
actually cities with worse crime rate
yeah I think East st. Louis is still
ahead of us per capita okay no see
so we got that going for it we're still
second city even in crime we're second
to self oh no we're fucking Gotham City
but it you know we're not New York City
this is that oh I won't defend this shit
oh but I'm just saying that we're nicer
here this is just okay like okay
honestly walking on the streets of New
York how many like nice people did you
meet versus people that literally like
stole your umbrella and beat you with it
cuz that happened to me was over J it
was alright I got stories but yeah but I
with all of it I mean to the crammed
with a be everything New York Jersey
Chicago I get it it's not like although
just dicks for no reason no you have to
be I mean as totally understandable so
it's not like slow no you shoot our own
not true so um wow we just might not
hold on a ferngully they brought it up
favorite Jersey Jersey they brought it
somehow we got a feel that we went off
on the Oneida from Jersey let's just
let's settle this right now we're not
talking about New York we're talking
about Empire City yeah those New York
City is completely fine Empire City Shox
and not New Jersey to just Jersey just
Jersey yeah see
this is all Steven universe as well yeah
and that they'll have like it's a just
call light shy town or something like
that and I'll just be like everyone's
dead from eating to buy everyone just
has my heart it's just one giant
deep-dish pizza with a city but I could
cling on to some sports team saying we
could still win
Gabbar good got it it's only fair and I
had to attack us too
oh yes our food is amazing that it is
and it will kill you in a microsecond
it's designed to make you hibernate
that's how we get you are we deep-dish
pizza like bears we're talking about
bear Osito fish like and then we just
hibernate for six months we're talking
about this episode so uh what is there
left to talk about um you know how
peridot and lambdas are they gonna give
it loan
I guess the next episode of fight fight
fight let's just um no I I really like
this I like especially the backstory I
thought the colors and the simple
background the simple shapes are though
very effective and but I'm can't with
you it's like it was so slow moving and
fine is the best story bit in the middle
when suddenly all the info comes like
whoa
cuz I the same thing happened to me I
sort of tuned out for like a half second
I was like whoa um but uh no I thought
was really nice I like seeing this
character back one question for you uh
because when we first saw her really
after it went off and all that you want
to ask me do you know H I do uh when you
first saw laughs at the way first year
she had mirrors for eyes everything was
reflected back uh
and then like she blinks II see her
realize would you think it'd be more
effective as she had them your eyes all
the time or if she had Esau the pupils
no animation 101 eyes are the windows to
the soul if you really want to forge a
connection with the character you're
gonna need to see that that is my
thought but there's also like that's why
anime works that's why Disney works no
no but I that's why anime copied off it
but I was gonna say I kind of like
because I've seen his dumb characters
before even though you're right about
the eyes that disconnect is sometimes
makes them a little bit more intriguing
than first and we didn't know than half
of garnet had only one eye cuz her eyes
were always covered but we're not ok so
there's also like that disconnect that
makes you a little bit
or at the point where lapis is supposed
to be mysterious but also we're supposed
to sympathize with yes so I don't get
what the point of doing that would be I
feel like I'd have more of a traveler
life like she doesn't even have eyes
like we're supposed to feel man she
doesn't even have eyes it just makes her
more sad but it doesn't allow for as
much expression oh I think where they're
going with this I don't think it would
work well I was gonna say especially cuz
it's simply more more that won't make
her like a real welcome risk if we were
in the in-between stage where she's
becoming my like I could see it working
there but at this point I'm like what's
clear they just want to make her
sympathetic at some point he tried to
show the real eyes so yeah and then well
it'll be interesting if they keep her
around like to keep peridot around I
mean beige you'll be a railer now people
from Jersey they have me rise
I think they burn through your soul it's
like it reflects off their that's why
they're so angry because they look at
one now then they see themselves I uh
is there anyone anyone on the planet we
have an affair I hope not I'm hoping we
got everybody including our own shitbird
yeah no I mean that that's the fun I
don't discriminate I hate everybody I
hate myself yeah especially you dick